panoramedics did all they could to try
to save those two students but they
could not be helped and we are hearing
more about them at this morning one of
the students was Barnaby Weber and his
parents David and Emma have paid tribute
to him they said they were proud of him
and that his death had left his younger
brother Charlie bereft in a statement
they said complete Devastation is not
enough to describe our pain and loss at
the senseless murder of our son Barnaby
Philip John Weber was a beautiful
brilliant bright young man with
everything in life to look forward to as
parents we are enormously proud of
everything he achieved and all the plans
he made and he was a big cricketer as
well he played for the University team
and for his local team in Taunton in
Somerset both of those teams have paid
tribute to him as well and his team in
Somerset has encouraged people to go and
lay flowers in tribute to him there and
the former England cricket captain
Michael Vaughan has said he is a young
cricketer Gone Too Soon and the young
woman who also lost her life 19 year old
Grace Kumar was a talented hockey player
played for the University and her
country as well and this morning England
Hockey have tweeted we are all deeply
saddened by the news of the tragic death
of Grace Kumar in Nottingham on Tuesday
Grace was a popular member of the
England under-16 and under 18 squads and
our thoughts are with Grace's family
friends teammates and the whole hockey
community at this time and we wait to
hear more details as well about the man
in his 50s who died of knife injuries
before his van was stolen and used to
run down three other people one of those
people is in a critical condition in
hospital two others thankfully only
received minor injuries but the suspect
is still being questioned by police on
suspicion of murder and we are expecting
further vigils to take place today and
tomorrow in memory of those students